the amount of opioid related deaths
Rises every year reaching new now even
haunting records two FDA advisory
committees say the medicine used to
reverse overdoses should be more
accessible Ryan Matthey shows us the
latest and also shares the survival
story of a local Mother
I died you know Christy Del Santo has
been in this situation twice it shook me
but not to the point where it shook me
straight
heroin her drug of choice a Mississippi
native turned Las Vegas her second
relapse was this year now she's a mother
to a two-month-old son but she almost
wasn't it took paramedics to inject me
with two shots and two nasal sprays both
times and I came back what saved her was
this Narcan nasal spray reversing her
overdoses and saving her life twice it's
currently available behind the counter
but FDA advisors want to cut out the
pharmacist making it available over the
counter and medical professionals agree
from a medical perspective it's like
absolutely that's like having an insulin
Dr farzar kamyar is a psychiatrist
specializing in substance use disorders
and works with pregnant women and new
mothers at Roseman University who use
opioids it instantly reverses everything
that's associated with an opioid
overdose the recommendation he calls
life-saving especially so amidst a
worsening opioid epidemic and the
increasing detection of fentanyl in
other drugs like non-dispensary
marijuana and meth the CDC reporting 69
000 opioid overdose deaths nationally in
2020 that number increasing 17 percent
the next year and concerns that a baby
or someone not experiencing an overdose
is exposed the cool thing is is that
nothing happens this mother hoping
others like her get to experience the
joy of life it's more accessible there
will be more more people out there
willing to save lives
now the ultimate decision is in the
hands of the FDA commissioner it's still
unclear if and when it even be approved
and how much a standard nasal spray
would even cost